[Musik]
Tatort Deutschland die crime-doku von
Bild
seit über 50 Minuten mordet an der
spreeweg bereits auf der Insel ja die
jungen Camp Bewohner der norwegischen
Arbeiterpartei suchen Schutz im Dickicht
des Waldes oder am Ufer der kleinen
Insel manche haben previk nicht einmal
gesehen hören nur seine tödlichen
Schüsse die auf ihre Freunde feuert
vielleicht sehen sie auch die grauen
Wolken über der Insel nachdem der
Rechtsextremist zwei Rauchgranaten
zündet seit fast einer Stunde Haaren die
kämpfewohner in ihren Verstecken aus
Versuchen keinen Mucks von sich zu geben
viele ihrer Freunde sind bereits tot
bildchef Reporter Peter hell hat mit
vielen augenzeugendes 22 juli 2011
gesprochen er ist quasi
schlafwandlerisch wie ein Soldat wie
eine perfekte mord-maschine über die
Insel gegangen und hat sich darauf
ausgesucht und dann eben die Kinder
quasi zu jagen und dann zu exekutieren
Menschen die also vor dem vor dem Boden
kneten und um Gnade gepfleht haben hat
der eiskalt exekutiert vor den Augen
ihrer Freunde an einem Sommertag im Jahr
2011 zündet Anna spreiwig eine Bombe in
Oslo und richtet danach ein Massaker auf
der Insel ja an das ist das Thema
unserer zweiteiligen Sonderfolge zum 12
Jahrestag
willkommen zurück bei Tatort Deutschland
falls ihr Teil 1 noch nicht gehört haben
sollte dann empfehlen wir euch diesen
zuerst zu hören bevor es jetzt hier mit
Teil zwei weitergeht mein Name ist Mirko
Kasimir und ich bin Toni Heyer hallo
seit kurz nach 17 Uhr ist der
Rechtsextremist bereits auf der Insel
utroya gegen 18 Uhr sind immer noch
keine Einsatzkräfte am Tatort die
Jugendlichen und Betreuer sind also
komplett auf sich allein gestellt aber
wieso dauert es so lange bis Hilfe
überhaupt da ist das ist eine gute Frage
als die Camp Bewohner die ersten Schüsse
hören wählen Sie natürlich sofort den
Notruf aber berichten zufolge soll den
Personen auf Ute ja erstmal nicht
zugehört worden sein sie sollen die
Leitung für andere Anrufe offen lassen
denn wir erinnern uns Norwegen ist zu
dem Zeitpunkt bereits im kompletten
alarmmodus weniger als drei Stunden
zuvor zündete Breivik eine Bombe in Oslo
die acht Menschen tötete
als der Rechtsextremist auf uterjahr
ankommt gehen die Einsatzkräfte noch
davon aus dass eine zweite Bombe in Oslo
explodiert was den rettungsprozess
außerdem verzögert ist dass kein
Polizeihubschrauber einsatzfähig ist und
die Polizisten die bereits auf der
anderen Seite des Ufers sind keine Boote
bekommen das ist so schrecklich also bei
so einem Amoklauf erzählt wirklich jede
Sekunde die Rettung kommt dann durch
eine Polizei Eliteeinheit genannt Delta
die Gruppe trainiert an diesem
verhängnisvollen Tag durch Zufall in der
Nähe von Oslo und ist somit
verhältnismäßig schnell einsatzbereit um
18:25 Uhr liegt das erste Boot der
delta-einheit auf der Insel an schon am
Steg hören die eliteeinsatzkräfte
brewingsschüsse Stück für Stück arbeiten
sich die Einsatzkräfte vor auf ihrem Weg
passieren Sie die Leichen der
kämpfewohner neben der Inselschule in
der Miriam aus Teil 1 seit nunmehr einer
Stunde
entdeckt die delta-einheit Breivik auf
seinem blutigen Streifzug
steht auf einem Trampelpfad im Wald und
hält sein Gewehr im Anschlag
die Einsatzkräfte fordern den Attentäter
auf seine Waffe abzulegen Breivik
gehorcht lehnt sein Gewehr gegen einen
Baum und beginnt den Polizisten entgegen
zu laufen aus brevixweste hängt ein
Kabel die Eliteeinheiten überlegen ob
rewig vorhat sich in die Luft zu
springen sie hätten dann die Erlaubnis
Breivik zu erschießen
der Massenmörder nähert sich den
Polizisten weiter und weiter und bleibt
dann plötzlich stehen die Eliteeinheit
erkennt dass das Kabel zu breivik's
Kopfhörer gehört und kann den Attentäter
völlig widerstandslos festnehmen um kurz
nach 6:30 Uhr ist braves Blutbad beendet
mehr als 70 Minuten mordete er auf
Breivik wird ins Haupthaus gebracht und
die Insel evakuiert darunter ist auch
die Inselschule in der sich Miriam aus
Teil 1 versteckt die Polizisten bringen
sie und die weiteren Überlebenden ans
Ufer doch auf dem Weg dorthin brennen
sich furchtbare Bilder ein Jahre später
teilt Miriam ihre Erinnerung mit Bild
so schnell wir gingen runter zum
Boots
herum saß grausam aus verwundete Kinder
es lang tote um uns herum die zum Glück
abgedeckt waren
liegen große Steine die von Moos
überwachsen sind daneben ragen kleine
Bäume in den Himmel die Wellen brechen
leise jetzt nach dem Attentat liegen auf
den Steinen die Körper von Betreuern und
Jugendlichen die sich am Ufer vor
Breivik in Sicherheit bringen wollten
Anna sprayvic tötet 69 Menschen allein
auf Italia mindestens genauso viele sind
verletzt einige müssen ins Krankenhaus
Norwegen steht unter Schock während die
Menschen noch dabei waren das blutige
Bombenattentat aus Oslo zu verarbeiten
erreichen Sie die nächsten Meldungen
über den Amoklauf auf Italia Eltern
Angehörige und Freunde fahren
unmittelbar zum Tatort wollen wissen wie
es ihren Kindern geht ob ihre Kinder
unter den Opfern sind lies bald ist eine
von ihnen ihre Tochter Sinne was damals
18 Jahre alt und im Ferienlager auf
Youtube ja über das Radio verfolgte
liest Bett die furchtbaren Entwicklungen
auf der Insel und fährt unmittelbar
dorthin als sie ankommt ist ihre ja
abgesperrt alle Angehörigen müssen sich
in einem Hotel auf dem
gegenüberliegenden Festland versammeln
Jahre später berichtet Lisbeth wie sie
diesen schrecklichen Tag erlebte
ich schrieb ihr aber sie antwortete
nicht ich habe den ganzen Abend versucht
sie anzurufen aber sie hobt nicht ab
Strukturen also mit dem Auto los und als
wir dort ankamen ich erinnere mich noch
war es sehr chaotisch wir liefen ins
Hotel und suchten nach Sinnen ich dachte
ich könnte sie einfach mit nach Hause
nehmen andere Rezeption lagen Listen aus
mit den Namen derjenigen die überlebt
hatten aber wir konnten ihren Namen
nicht finden wir lasen es rückwärts und
wieder vorwärts und jeden Namen immer
und immer wieder aber ihrer stand nicht
drauf
über eine Liste zu erfahren dass die
eigene Tochter tot ist
das ist wirklich unfassbar schrecklich
zeitgleich mit den Angehörigen fahren
auch die ersten Journalisten nach Utoya
Peter hell ist damals einer von ihnen
heute erzählt er uns von seiner
Erlebnissen die Leichen wurden dann
natürlich geborgen es waren überall das
konnte man später sehen weiße
Leichentücher auch an den Ufern wo die
Beamten die toten Körper abgedeckt haben
dann und das Szenario war halt furchtbar
weil die Kinder und Jugendliche mussten
natürlich mit den Leichenwagen mit
schwarzen Leichenwagen abtransportiert
werden und zwar eine richtige Prozession
eine Leichen Prozession die schwarzen
Leichenwagen so viel gab es überhaupt
nicht die wurden aus den ganzen
Ortschaften wurden die angefordert wo in
jedem Auto ein toter Mensch lag ein
toter Jugendliche ein Kind und das war
schon eine sehr beängstigende furchtbare
Optik
an diesem 22 juli 2011 tötet an der
spreeweg insgesamt 77 Menschen und
während Angehörige Freunde und das ganze
Land in Schockstarre verharren Beginn an
der spreiwegs Vernehmungen
Profiler beschreiben ihn als
hochintelligenten Menschen der immer
mehr in eine Parallelwelt abdriftete und
sich radikalisierte außerdem erfahren
die Ermittler wie Anna sperrweg seine
Tat im Voraus plante Monate bevor in
Oslo brevix Bombe explodiert und damit
das Grauen über Norwegen hereinbricht
mietete sich der Rechtsextremist einen
Bauernhof im Dorf AStA ca 170 km von
Oslo entfernt hier tarnte er sich als
Gemüsebauer doch eigentlich baute
Breivik hier seine Bomben und trainierte
für seinen Tag X
der Rechtsextremist wollte fit sein
wollte genau 80 Kilo wiegen nicht 78
nichts war und 80 genau 80 nur so denkt
bei Weg sei er fähig seine geplanten
Attentate zu verüben wenn sein
Kampfgeist wie er sagte schwach war ging
er raus in den Wald und hörte Nazi Musik
abends ließ er sich in der Kneipe im Ort
ein Bierzapfen aufgefallen ist Breivik
hier nicht
die Vernehmungen dauern insgesamt neun
Monate bis im April 2012 der Prozess
gegen Anna spreiwig beginnt das Gericht
muss insbesondere entscheiden ist
Breivik böse oder verrückt denn die
Experten kommt diesbezüglich zu einem
unterschiedlichergebnis noch im Jahr
2011 attestieren zwei Gutachter Breivik
eine paranoide Schizophrenie kurz vor
Prozessbeginn fallen wiederum zwei
andere Ärzte das Urteil dass es keine
Anzeichen für eine Psychose bei dem
Massenmörder gebe somit geht es für
Breivik um Gefängnis oder Psychiatrie
vor Gericht zeigt bei wie keine Reue
seine Aussagen sind ein
Menschenverachtung kaum zu überbieten
die Schuld für den Anschlag läge bei den
Politikern und der Presse
sein Ziel war es alle Personen auf Ute
ja zu töten und das einzige was nach
Breiviks Meinung nach falsch sei war das
Minderjährige unter seinen Opfern waren
er konnte ihr Alter so Breivik jedoch
nicht erkennen weil sie sich von ihm
abwendeten als er sie erschoss Breivik
spricht dabei ganz ruhig hinter ihm im
Gerichtssaal sitzen Angehörige und
Personen die sein Attentat nur knapp
überlebt haben immer wieder heilen ihre
Schluchzer durch den Raum selbst während
der Zeugenaussagen lächelt der
Massenmörder glücklich vor sich hin als
vor Gericht Ausschnitte aus Breiviks
propaganda-film gezeigt werden da kommen
ihm die Tränen im Sommer 2012 fällt die
Richterin das Urteil gegen Breivik 21
Jahre Haft mit anschließender
Sicherheitsverwahrung
nach Prozess Ende wird der Attentäter in
ein Hochsicherheitsgefängnis überführt
doch Breivik schafft es auch mehr als
zehn Jahre nach seinen tödlichen
Attentaten seine Opfer zu verhöhnen so
klagt er mal auf eine vorzeitige
Entlassung mal auf bessere
Haftbedingungen bei Gericht hebt er
seine Hand inzwischen zum Hitlergruß
keiner von breivik's Anträgen gibt durch
er sitzt noch immer im
Hochsicherheitsgefängnis in Norwegen
auf uto Jahr finden inzwischen wieder
Feriencamps statt doch den Anschlag vom
22 juli 2011 wird man hier nie vergessen
die ganze Insel gleicht einem Mahnmal
für Breiviks Tat die nationale
Gedenkstätte für die Todesopfer steht
hier am Ufer ein großes Kunstwerk das
aus 77 Bronze sterben besteht ein Stab
für jedes Opfer viele Gebäude auf der
Insel wurden renoviert die Cafeteria
jedoch nicht in den Wänden sieht man bis
heute die Einschusslöcher einmal im Jahr
kommen auf Ute Jahr die Angehörigen
zusammen und gedenken ihrer Liebsten die
ihnen brevic so gewaltvoll genommen hat
an diesem 22 juli 2011
und das war unser Fall für heute bei
Tatort Deutschland noch sind wir
eigentlich in der Sommerpause das heißt
nächste Woche hört ihr uns noch mal mit
einem reallout aber august gibt es dann
aber neue Folgen für euch dazu dann aber
noch mal mehr danke dass ihr heute mit
dabei wart und ich hoffe dass er auch
beim nächsten Mal wieder einschaltet
eure Toni und euer Mirko unsere Quellen
sind die Bilddokumentation das Grauen
von Ute ja von Peter hell und Annika
rasch außerdem Berichte aus dem Spiegel
der SZ und dem Deutschlandfunk Skript
Lilly von der Osten Postproduktion
Studios Mädchen